welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode 4 that sorte aka
the spaghetti episode we've actually
known this episode was coming for a
while like back at New York ComicCon
Adult Swim President Michael oene The
Adult Swim president teased that this
episode would sit alongside pickle Rick
in the bat of acid episode as one of the
most memorable in the show's history and
you know what I think he's right writer
Heather an cample came up with a
brilliant episode of the series that
thematically parallels season 4's V of
acid in so many ways so let's break down
all the animation details the Easter
eggs the inside jokes and the deeper
layers of meaning content warning though
the episode we are breaking down has to
do with self harm so if you are not
interested in that kind of content you
don't need to keep watching okay we open
with who's ready for Rick's famous
spaghetti based on everyone's unhinged
enthusiasm we know something's going to
be off about this spaghetti and the
animators include a Troublesome little
wobble and a drip of buet sauce from
that casserole dish that we're just like
yuck what is this summer Chucks her
smartphone against the wall and it
breaks in half whatever text
conversation she was having the green
bubble means that there's some non-ios
user in the chat there gross but the
screen goes black on the break and Morty
runs in with his bib already on Rick
says that's some good spaghetti Grandpa
Rick I am skull emoji but words yeah he
uses a classic Italian hand gesture that
actually comes from a 1969 ala salzo
commercial Mama M that's a spicy meat
ball Morty says so nice that we're
talking you know all talking because
we're a family and and this is a good
time we're having yeah this whole idea
of families bonding over spaghetti
dinners combined with the social anxiety
over where our food comes from and
factory farming was Ryder Heather and
Campbell's root concept like she told
variety spaghetti is the family meal
when you're growing up and your mom
makes something it's going to be
spaghetti so the idea that Rick has been
offis scating the truth of where his
spaghetti is coming from and an
artificial attempt to create this
familial experience felt pretty on the
nose Campbell also wrote the Panda
Express fortune cookie episode from
season 6 final desmith and admitted a
lot of her pitches and end up being food
based she continued there's so many
different ways in which we are
barricaded from the truth of everything
that we enjoy and I think that the
puzzle of being alive is how to
reconcile that when a wolf eats a rabbit
the wolf's not like worried about it it
is a very specific experience to Being
Human to being conscious of something in
a way that nothing else in the animal
kingdom seems to have to digest digest
oh they're always working at some great
jokes and everything Morty realizes that
the spaghetti comes from a corpse why is
it always this with you of course
it's a person Rick why couldn't it just
be spaghetti hop to keep this on a small
scale and didn't intend on the operation
heightening to a global crisis but it's
Morty who takes it to that extreme just
like Morty does in the timeline respawn
device in the bad of acid episode Rick
takes Morty to the planet 41 Kepler b a
planet that's like a small version of
Earth like the skyscrapers and mountains
are visible from space and jut up from
the surface and I actually think there's
some significance to why this planet is
the size of this Rick explains that on
this planet people who end their own
lives turn into spaghetti what I know
you're a visual learner so follow me
yeah Rick resents people who need visual
aids Beyond his verbal explanations
Allah his PowerPoint joke last episode I
also love how his lasers put Morty in a
backless hospital gown but for Rick it
just adds a stethoscope to his outfit
which is already a doctor's white lab
coat Rick slices open the bodies in that
first one the murder victim has the
shape of a you know in the Gin region
there yeah this show in its hidden
Dickies the corpses innards are
delicious
spaghetti come on Morty cho cho plane
come on choo choo plane is a hilarious
nonsensical thing that I'm going to do
with my future kid but I assume it's
because Rick considers normal human
aircraft to be as Antiquated as trains
which is why he kind of seems dismissive
when he brings up Kitty Hawk later Rick
explains their cortisol increases the
starch content in their bloodstream
changing their intestines into one long
spaghetti noodle and the surrounding
tissues into a spicy sweet hematoma that
we would call A B yes cortisol is a
steroid hormone produced by the adrenal
glands released when you are stressed or
even when you just scream cortisol just
comes out and it's just got to be a
coincidence that this episode drops
during season 2 of Loki which features
characters Dying by spaghettify a
concept pulled from theoretical physics
in which those who enter black holes are
condensed into one long noodle strand of
themselves and Rick's usual puke dribble
has been replaced with even grosser
blood clot tomato sauce the coroner
catches them and Rick pulls out a memory
wiper before you do that just Rick stop
what where am I in a morg eating bodies
what stop using that thing what thing
who are we we were just leaving all you
had to say yeah I just love the Ry jok
at episode there being some dark
shortcut phrase for anyone on this
planet that's all you had to say but
this device is of course based on the
neuralyzer from Men In Black Rick
doesn't want to wear sunglasses to
protect his own eyes from The Flash and
he always just aims it the wrong way but
we know Rick has a lot of experience
with like memory wiping and backups to
reset your memories as we saw in the
Morty's mind-blower episode after Morty
promises he just wants to know the
spaghetti people's names and not go to
their funerals we go to one of the
funerals immediately the church is a
symbol of a cross with a semicircle
cutting through it just a lot of little
details that make this just a slightly
Earth Rick growls on their way in the
only reason you're still alive is
because you don't turn delicious when
you die yeah that greeter at the church
store side eyes rck on that one
wondering why this grandpa is
threatening cannibalism now no one wants
to speak at Lawrence's funeral so Morty
tries to do the right thing it brought
us together Lawrence brought us together
it just felt wrong not having anyone
know that but he was delicious I I hope
that helps make it right Rick will prove
later this episode that visuals work
better than words show don't tell which
is ironic considering rck previously
mocked visual aids and visual learners
but notice Lawrence's two kids sitting
in that front Pew Lawrence was Amber's
husband the carpenter of the year that
she left for Fred bunk in the episode's
Montage in the Final Act he has the same
exact hairstyle as the corpse that we
saw in the garage and the photo that she
shows Fred during that Montage shows the
full family with those same two kids now
you'll notice his hair had not grayed
when his corpse was in Rick's garage but
based on how fast everything progressed
resses on the spaghetti planet and how
small this planet is compared to Earth I
think that time progresses faster people
age faster and that Lauren took his own
life sometime after Amber left him for
Fred we see an attendee filming Morty
speech with his phone and I just like
the little art design details on the
phones and the cars all being a bit more
angular than the normal Earth designs
Morty tells the family summer it was
people it's people a reference to the
famous line from the movie soilent Green
a movie in which an unwitting populace
consumes processed humans for food and
Charlton hon screams to the greatest
people this episode shows the society
embracing that though in the marketing
stamping it's people on the cans and the
boxes Jerry gripes first octopus now
this have we thought about just giving
up and joining the fascist half of the
country just saying they get to do more
octopi are surprisingly intelligent they
have emotions and memories and can feel
pain just remember that Morty watches
porn with a very specific bad family
therapist farm girl on a website that
kind of looks like the layout of PornHub
we're reminded of Morty's liberal Kink
when it comes to plantina in a rck
convenient Mort when she became an eot
terrorist and he had to reject her 41
Kepler B since a shuttle there is an
actual planet called Kepler 41b it's a
gas giant discovered in 2011 Mor boards
the shuttle can that thing support my
weight it
should okay um up
here jeez ever heard of a ramp this is a
ramp yeah I don't really have anything
to say here I just love this bit so
Morty is greeted by the spaghetti Planet
president Hi Morty I'm the president of
this planet yeah it looks like her
character was based visually at least on
Camala Harris the Oval Office has
portraits of women from throughout their
history maybe all past presidents of
this planet have been women and that's
why you have presidents of the entire
planet because they didn't have like
borders and wars and bought over stupid
but this President is far from
perfect she sees an opportunity of a Dr
Koran argument of a right to die as a
way to profit so long as as they consent
to do so which would make the spaghetti
ethically sourced so they find a new
chief export and Morty serves ethical
spaghetti and I like how this scene
starts with a two camera shot that
mirrors Ricks at the beginning of the
episode pass the parmesian yes parmesian
a call back to the parmesian universe
where no one can pronounce the word
parmesan we saw that in the season 6
premiere the exact same as our old
timeline so they do say parmesan weird
how do they say parmesian
Rick reveals the spaghetti planet has
been profiting from Morty approved moros
obviously based on SpaghettiOs and Rick
plays the recording hi I'm Roger Wayne
martyr I was a serial killer in Cannibal
and now I get to kill myself and be food
for you which I suppose is a silver
lining to all my misdeeds yeah serial
killers are often known by their first
middle and last name and his middle name
is Wayne like John Wayne gasy Jeffrey
dmer though was the most infamous
Campbell serial killer but his last name
is Martyr which he yes does sound like
murder but it's also the surname of
headwriter of this show Scott martyr the
spaghetti planet has clearly gone to
a homeless man had a poster with
the ended nigh written on it which is
the same text to the sign that R shark
carried and Watchmen before the world
experienced their squid pocalypse this
guy I got to say kind of looks like a
bald version of Dan Harmon now long time
new rockstars viewers know how much we
use geology and how long we've been
using it for but if this is your first
time hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 G will give
you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to geol log. i/
rockstars 100 to get started they pass
various Billboards they are living life
well because you left the billboard
below at first looks like the word
rapists before the camera shifts down to
reveal its therapists and you can rede
for free brought to you by the better
spaghetti Bureau the idea I guess being
they don't need therapists anymore now
that they're encouraging ending at all
Rick flies past the most scenic jump he
says a bridge that looks like San
Francisco's Golden Gate Bridge the
Golden Gate Bridge is sadly a common
destination for this kind of thing but
thankfully there is some fencing and
usually there are people there on the
lookout to talk to any troubled people
who might walk out there alone there's
actually a 2006 documentary called the
bridge about people who had jumped from
it and yeah some people have survived
that Fallen under the water a good
reminder here that if you need help
please do not hesitate to call 988 it is
available 24 hours in this episode we
see that the spaghetti Planet removed
the safety rails of the bridge and made
them into pasta colanders visually
recalling the colander that Rick used in
his garage for his brain swapping but
thankfully we don't see anyone dropping
into those colanders here the variety of
article details that there were versions
of the episode that would have seen
people leaping off buildings and turning
into spaghetti or where Rick was the one
who had the crisis of conscience or
where Morty became a spaghetti dealer in
the vein of Walter White they said
underlying it all was the tonal
Balancing Act of making comedy about
large scale self-inflicted profit driven
death Rick says that on the radio it's
not all Ina as Morty guesses but rather
all morning Zoo teams just patter no
songs oh and for TV wall to--all reality
television but not the good kind it's
like their whole planet was bought by
Discovery and is while they fly past a
changing billboard with the shows
infidelity Island Inseparable sisters a
nature show called that's dinner but
yeah this is all a hit on Rick and
Morty's parent company Warner discovery
which has flooded the max streaming
service with titles like 90day fiance
and mil Manor the President says with
what's coming in from Intergalactic
spaghetti trade we've decreased our debt
are making a lot of
money we've got clean energy that space
where you paused is where you should
have said mental health care and Morty
realizes he just made things worse if
you help me I I promise I'll never look
under the curtain at a rick thing to
figure out what's bad about it ever
again and you can never say no to me
what are you Keith Ren Erie Keith Rin
Erie a reference to the leader of the
Nexium cult that gaslit its members into
all sorts of horrible things for more
details on this watch another Warner
Discovery title The Vow Mor's solution
is to use clones for this what are you
suggesting here a sped up lifespan and
indoctrination program limiting their
exposure to the world and convincing
them that becoming spaghetti is their
Destiny and another sci-fi consequence
immediately progressed to 3 Days Later
where we see two clones fleeing into the
forest and shooting each other again
time moves just way too fast on this
planet I think it's because it's so
small now yes we have seen this Trope in
the 2010 movie never let me go based on
the 2005 novel Rick cites that here
sorry spoiler warning but it's also a
familiar concept we've seen in a lot of
things like 2005's film The Island which
itself was ripped off from a 1979 movie
called Parts the Clon is horror Rick
says H I guess all clone stories turn
out the same way this does not bode well
for his daughter considering she has
been cloned let's just remember this
line for later this season because it
might lead to some kind of dark fate for
somebody Morty asks about clones who
aren't exactly people and Rick's an
expert in Gray areas his first subject
is someone with no frontal lobe no
empathy sensors but since his subject
doesn't know the difference between life
and death no spaghetti because remember
the spaghettification is based on the
hormone of cortisol which comes from the
adrenal gland the next subject which
Rick says would be in unimaginable pain
from the moment it's born he hadn't even
made because he knew Morty would object
you might want to examine the trolley
problem at some point Morty yes the
trolley problem is the utilitarian
thought experiment where it says you can
see a trolley headed for a track with
five people on it but if you pull a
lever it would divert the TR probably to
one person so you would have saved those
five people but killed the one this
whole concept was explored in an amazing
episode of the good place now the last
clone is just a torso with motor
functions Morty panes giving the clone a
claw to stab itself all you had to say
so this leads to a factory that is
inspired by lab grown meat that's meat
made from animal cells as opposed to
living animals it's more expensive to
produce now but might become more common
place in the future if consumers accept
it now this meat is not considered
vegetarian unlike impossible foods and
Beyond foods but the torsos go down the
assembly line to this jazzy music
inspired by the classic song Powerhouse
that's a song that plays in Looney Tunes
every time we see any kind of factory
sequence so they are cut open and I
don't want to show you too much of it
but other than the spaghetti that comes
out there's also some dark waste showing
that it's not the same pure spaghetti
two different groups of protesters
attack torsos rights and real spaghetti
The Old Spaghetti faction seems to be
aliens but there is a brain in a jar
that kind of looks like crank from TMNT
they blow up the factory Society
collapses actually we see on the roof of
one building there is is a corpse that
has turned into spaghetti so Rick has
one more idea a terminally ill patient
with 2 months to live named Fred bunk
who refuses to feed the sick system but
Rick talks him into engaging in this
experiment to give his death meaning so
he takes him to this euthanasia chamber
that was already ready to go with a
viewing gallery for people to watch
likely Rick built this place for himself
to use someday I assume Rick hijacks the
airwaves and tells Fred to think about
his life now this room is a color orange
reminding me of the end of life Chamber
from soilent Green in which the guy
requested that the color orange be cast
on the walls as he looked at a montage
of pleasant imagery Rick Compares this
to the wght brothers at Kittyhawk
referring to the location in North
Carolina where the W brothers first flew
their playing that they named the right
flyer he believes empathy will be as
revolutionary for everybody watching as
flying was for us which I love because
the song Live Forever includes the lyric
maybe I just want to fly want to live I
don't want to die what follows is a
beautiful piece of animated visual
storytelling recalling the Montage from
the bad of acid episode and set to this
Oasis song Live Forever that's covered
here by ktoi and Ryan Elder Heather and
Campbell told variety quote what was
most important to me about that sequence
is that when we see those montages of
people's lives and movies they always
follow a very standard Arc interested in
a thing gets a job at the thing makes
the thing and life is not like that at
all it is a huge number of detours and
disappointments that make your life it's
not a direct path it's like a river with
a bunch of branches so unlike the
Montage and Pixar's Up or the bad of
asson Montage or even the Royal life
well-lived video game Fred's life is
messy it takes unexpected turns with
random recurring themes but doesn't
really fit a perfect narrative structure
and that's what makes it so touching so
the first thing we see is Fred in his
crib he has a stuffed rabbit with a
strawberry and a strawberry on the
mobile setting up his Lifelong Love of
strawberry jelly he plays with toys
these aren't Tinker Toys they're
actually called constructs which is an
actual building toy that debuted in 1983
it's been discontinued and then
resurrected a few different times then
he eats jelly as the urban building
Skyline is behind the jelly linking the
two things he loves in life the
sweetness of straw straberries in the
visual Majesty of a well-designed city
and we'll see how Amber fits into both
of those because the teacher then snaps
at him for doodling but Amber is sitting
to the side taking pity on him there
then he meets Amber when he's a bit
older by his locker in the trophy case
we see the years 1953 and 1954 in sports
ball on the Jersey Brad shows Amber his
room with the models he's building based
on vundam and Chaz andv Hotel Tower
which look like this planet's Big Ben in
notredam Cathedral they graduate but
then they split up when Fred Goes to
College we see him struggling in his
architect classes he calls Amber on a
video phone that has a rotary dial which
is another great little alternate World
detail we see Fred dropping out of
school meeting another girl drinking
some booze based on a less sweet fruit
Mero can but misses Amber throughout all
this he drives over the Golden Gate
Bridge and his car swerves ever so
slightly which is so sad to me it's that
dark Instinct kicking in but he stops
himself but Amber won't take him back so
he moves back in with his parents they
pass away and he rediscovers his toys
but frustrated with these constructs he
designs his own toys that he calls Fred
blocks which link together just like
Lego do he sells them on a shark tank
like show and they're huge success in
his Mansion we see Fred scrolling a
Facebook like site called friend book he
comes across Amber's profile then when
they meet over drinks he learns that
she's married but they kiss and she
leaves her husband we see a sign in
their house that reads Carpenter of the
year which means failing to lock down an
architect she married a carpenter and
again I'm almost certain this is
Lawrence same hairstyle same kids and
notice he has bandages around his
midsection maybe some injury down there
that would have made it easier for Rick
to crack open that Lobster and go
digging Amber completes her divorce they
grow old together and they eat
strawberry jelly so again this is not
like the perfect romance it's just kind
of like life and then on her headstone
look what's carved onto it a strawberry
also there's a headstone with the
spaghetti Planet cross that we pointed
out before and then Fred turns back up
to look at the skyline that inspired him
as a kid when he first ate from that
open jar of jelly Jesus Christ truly a
life well- lived so now after watching
this beautiful Journey Morty just can't
help but puke when he served the
spaghetti and Rick sums it up cells
consumed Morty life itself is wrong and
that means death is right but you can't
side with that so you live even when it
means eating and Fred here really did it
well Rick swaps out spaghetti night for
Salsbury steak night a food with
probably an even worse orchin and I want
to hear from you in the comments below
where you think that Salsbury steak
comes from the post credit seene shows a
vacuum and tree person planet we a Groot
like person in the euthanasia chamber
and you'll notice there's a rick vacuum
cleaner and a viewing Gallery behind
them has ramps instead of seats and
steps masses of vacuum cleaners watch
this there's a Louis Vuitton style store
called bag BHA a and when the vacuum
cleaners realize their bags come from
these beans they all spew out dust I
love this episode I think it's been the
best Rick and Morty episode in years at
least since that of acid I'm canceling
the rest of my night and calling a bone
scientist we're getting to the bottom of
this Jesus Christ enough already hey new
rock stars is doing a live show on
November 16th if you live in the LA area
it's at brain dead Studios on Fairfax
it's going to be a lot of fun ticket
info in the description please support
us with a loky themed we're all going to
die shirt available at nerd rot. shop
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network follow me on all
social platforms at eaos Big thanks to
Jordan Morris for helping me write this
breakdown thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye